- You may already know that I'm a doctor
but what I really want to be is a Shark.
The Dr. Shark is here. Big whoop.
- Esso Watches is a silicon watch company
focused on fashionable designs,
infused with negative ion technology.
- I love Mark Cuban's face,
right away when we start off,
the guy already knows it's BS.
He's like, "I'm not falling for it.
There's silicone in this, there's ions."
- Every day, our bodies are
bombarded by positive ions
which are molecules.
"Every day our bodies are
bombarded with molecules."
Yeah, like water molecules.
Like, when you take a shower?
"Every day, when you wake up
you're bombarded by molecules.
I'm talking about air and
then you get into the shower
and you're bombarded by more
molecules and that's water."
- Computers, TV's, fluorescent lighting.
Too much positive ion on our bodies
puts unnatural pressure on us.
- So things that exist in
the environment naturally,
causing pressure on us, is unnatural?
- It sounds a little,
you know...
- Fluffy?
- Well, it sounds a lot
like a coffee enema.
- You're trying to create a solution
for a non-existent problem.
And that just fails at the outset.
- Here you go.
- Thank you very much.
- Here's yours.
- No, thanks.
Go ahead. You keep it.
- It's Dallas Mavericks blue,
just for you.
- That's okay.
You keep it.
- Okay.
- Thank you.
- Oh, Mark's savage.
- Mark, are you allergic to
positive negative ion stuff?
- No. I'm allergic to scams.
- Oh!
- It's a joke.
It's a scam.
It's not real.
I'm out.
- Mark, I'm with you.
The Shark Varshavski's out.
- SynDaver Labs designs and builds
the world's most sophisticated
synthetic human tissues
and body parts.
Made from salt, water and
fiber, just like you and I,
our products employ materials
that mimic the properties
of human tissue.
These products are used
throughout the medical industry
to replace live animals,
human cadavers and even human patients
in trauma training, surgical education
and medical device development.
- I have probably used
one of these devices
and had no idea it was
made by this gentleman
or his company.
- This is about 85% water by mass.
It has every muscle, bone and organ
in natural human anatomy.
- [Lori] It almost feels
like chicken, raw chicken.
- [Dr. Christopher] It feels
exactly like live tissue.
- I love that instead of
saying it feels like a human
she said chicken.
(chicken clucks)
- Spent about 20 years
doing the development
of the tissues itself.
- [Doctor] He's really sweaty.
- Can you warm it up?
- And how do you
do surgery on it?
- Can you cut it?
- You can cut it.
It's basically a big 3D jigsaw puzzle.
- Ooh!
- Wow!
- It's a brand new system.
- Wow. He's sweating bullets.
- What's the price point
compared to a cadaver.
- It costs a lot more.
- Cadaver or this does?
- This is re-usable, a cadavers not.
- How much is this?
- A cadaver will cost you
five grand, 10 grand,
depending on where you are.
This is a $40,000 model
but you keep it forever.
(Sharks gasp)
- Oh!
- Do it again!
- Oh my God!
- Do it again! That was good.
Make the eyes close.
- I love that there's a $40,000 model,
real to life specifications
with muscles, bones, fibers.
It feels like humans,
or as Lori says chicken,
and they're excited that the eyelids close
with a little clunking sound.
(Sharks shriek)
Oh, that's cool.
I think that's a feature him
and his buddies put in like,
"Yo, let's get it to move."
I'm in, I'm sold, I want it.
- Hello.
- My name is Brandon Mars.
- Hey, Brandon Mars.
- This is my dad, Keith.
- Hey, Keith.
- And we're here today to talk
about something that nobody likes to do.
- What is one thing
that nobody likes to do?
Go to the DMV, clean, study?
- [Cameraman] Airport security?
The TSA?
- People like going
through airport security.
- Do they?
- Yeah 'cause it's like amaze.
- Swallow pills.
- What?
- We all like the benefits we get
from vitamins and supplements.
But did you know
that over a hundred million
people in the United States
alone-
- I didn't.
- cannot or have difficulty
swallowing pills?
- What's worse? They might not even work.
If you took a vitamin
B or a vitamin C pill
it may look like it's
the size of Pittsburgh.
You may only absorb 10 or 20% of it.
As a father of two boys who-
- Okay, I'm already about to be out
simply because of the names of the sprays.
Kids Spray. What is it,
like, to keep kids away?
Slim Spray. Are you gonna
get slim spraying that?
- C-Spray is our
multivitamin immunity blend
which has as much
vitamin C as 114 oranges.
- Do you really need 114
oranges worth of vitamin C?
I want you to think
of supplements as construction materials.
Imagine you're building a building
and all of a sudden you're
getting all the supplies
at the right rate, everything's fine.
You're building the building.
You're on schedule.
And then all of a sudden
the manufacturer ships you extra supplies
and expects you to finish the job sooner.
Would you be able to do that?
No. Why?
Rate-limiting step, actually
building the building.
It doesn't matter that you have
more supplies than you need.
Same goes with vitamins.
- ReBoot is our energy spray
which has a mega dose of vitamin B12.
- Oh, well a mega dose.
It doesn't, it gives you energy
'cause it probably has caffeine in it.
- Vitamin C.
You know it's good for
supporting your immune system.
If you've taken vitamin C pills or powders
for any of these benefits then get ready
because of the next evolution
of vitamin C is here.
And it's as simple as
spray, spray.
C-Spray, daily immune system support.
- Wow, that was high budget.
- Not bad.
- Very good.
- It was nicely done.
- Is it? Yo, check out
our YouTube channel guys.
- For the a hundred to 150 million people
that can't swallow pills-
- Are they really saying that half
of the U.S. population
can't swallow pills?
I prescribe pills all
the time in my practice.
Yes. Occasionally someone
will say, "Hey, doc,
can you give me the liquid
formulation instead?"
But that's a rare instance.
- I think you took a
different spray than I did.
You seem very irritable about this.
- It's a scam.
I mean, it's a hustle, right?
It's a hustle.
- Wait a second.
The whole supplement market's a hustle.
- Exactly.
- Mark calling them out.
Mr. Wonderful saying the
entire supplement industry
is a scam.
I'm on board with these guys.
And on that note, the
Doctor Shark, is out.
Yes.
- My name is Lani Lezzari.
I'm from Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania
and my company is Simple Sugars.
- Is it just me or does
her dress look like a cake?
Like it has frosting on it.
It has layers.
It looks like there's some berries on it.
- Since infancy I've suffered
from horrible eczema.
I couldn't find a single
product that I could safely use
on my sensitive skin, let alone one
that actually smelled good.
So as a determined 11-year-old,
I started doing research
and got to work creating the
product I was looking for.
- It's a shame that
doctors weren't looking for
cures for diseases.
We should just get 11-year-olds
to look for a cure to
all sorts of diseases,
we would solve them right away?
- My homemade creation not
only took away my eczema
but it also cleared out
my aunt's psoriasis.
Soon, I was getting requests
from my friends and
family to buy my products.
I couldn't pass up the opportunity
to become a business
woman, despite the fact
that I wasn't even a teenager yet.
Simple Sugars products are
all natural sugar scrubs.
They gently exfoliate
providing deep moisture
and complete skin
nourishment in one easy step.
- I'm curious, what's a sugar scrub?
Sugar is a molecule that,
on its own, is rough
and crystallized and
exfoliating in nature.
Does she repackage sugar
into a different container,
and probably she adds a
moisturizer or something,
and then call it a scrub?
- The result is super
smooth, great looking skin
without using a laundry list of products.
- Exfoliant is something that is rough,
that will take off the
superficial layer of dead skin.
In certain conditions like psoriasis
you actually have a forming
of several layers of this dead skin.
As a result, you get
plaques with psoriasis.
So taking off gently
that outer layer of skin
is actually a good thing
in some of these cases,
that's why people do exfoliate.
They buy all these different products
and actually some exfoliant products
are really bad for the environment
'cause they have little
plastic beads inside of them.
So having a natural
alternative, like sugar,
could be a great option.
- You said that it cured your
own eczema and psoriasis.
It's really hard to be able
to make a claim like that.
- It's not really hard to
make a claim like that.
It is illegal to make a claim like that
unless you have some kind of proof.
- We don't make any claims about
what the product will do for you.
What we do talk a lot about is
the benefits of each individual ingredient
which is something you can say
but we can't make any claims about it
curing eczema or psoriasis.
I can only speak from my experience.
- I like the product,
as long as they're not making
any wild claims, I'm in.
Let's get some sugar exfoliant
- Fluaway48 is a 100%
all natural medication
that has been clinically proven
to eliminate the symptoms
of the cold and flu, within
48 hours or your money back.
- Come on now.
No way she's making that claim.
Is this allowed in Australia?
Clinically proven or your money back
in two days to get rid of the flu.
The flu is not a benign
virus, influenza's serious.
If you ever tested positive for Flu A
you will be on your back.
- Wow.
- I love the difference
between the U.S. "Shark Tank"
and the Australian "Shark Tank".
In Australia, "Wow!"
In the U.S., "Scam!"
- It's a scam!
- It has been clinically
trialed on over 10,000 people
with a success rate of over 98.9%.
- Come on, why do they own it
as opposed to a pharmaceutical company?
Why do these two random individuals?
- Wow.
It's not often that people come in here
and say they're gonna
cure the common cold.
- She said flu.
She didn't say, she said
flu and common cold.
She didn't even distinguish
between the two viruses.
She's like, "It just fixes everything.
Your leg hurts? Two days."
- What is the product 'cause
it smells kind of unusual?
(laughs)
- Oh, only in Australia, I love it.
- Yeah, the products a hundred percent
natural ingredients, so there's garlic.
There's...
- Echinacea?
- There's no echinacea in it.
- It is, echinacea
- Oh, sorry.
- and vitamin C.
- [Both] Echinacea and vitamin C.
- Sorry.
- Did my guy just forget what's
in his own miracle potion?
Can you imagine I'm selling you this suit
and you're like, "So what's
good about this suit?"
I'm like, "It's a great suit."
You're like, "Well, I
like the color purple."
"No, it's not really purple."
"It is purple, I'm sorry, I just,
I forgot that I put my
life's work into this suit."
- Quickly.
- What part
of the immune system are you playing with?
- Um, Vitamin BS?
I bet he wished he wore
a tie in that moment.
Like, look, I'm really nervous.
(throat clears)
You see that? I bought
myself three seconds.
- We've had a professor from Harvard
look at this product in detail.
He's been involved for the last
four years.
- I'm seriously
looking forward to
reading a research paper.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's the path we're on.
- With evidence,
I'll roll over and say, "I'm wrong."
- They're trying to solve a problem
that the entire world's
scientific community
is trying to solve
because if you truly do solve it,
not only are you very wealthy
you will save countless lives.
And they thought they
did it with ingredients
that they have now changed,
remembered, forgot.
I'm out.
- Hi, my name is Jennifer Holland
and-
- They pitched me on this.
I don't know if I'm allowed to do this.
(tongue clicking)
All right. Conflict of interest
officially being disclosed.
I believe...
I think it's this product,
was shipped to me as a sample
and I did use them in my office.
I'm not gonna lie. They
were pretty awesome.
- Introducing Throat Scope,
illuminated tongue
depressor medical device.
Throat Scope is a one
hand operated device,
with a light source
located inside the mouth,
for fast accurate diagnosis.
- It's like a first-world
tongue depressor,
that's how I would put it.
- There is nothing currently on the market
for in-home oral cavity examination.
- Do you know what the number
one used product, nowadays,
for in-home oral examination?
In fact, when I was on the airplane
when the gentlemen went
into anaphylactic shock
and I administered a
makeshift epinephrin pen
I actually used my iPhone
light to consistently
check his oral airway to
make sure it was still open.
I don't know if this has
widespread implications or use
but I like it.
I would use it.
Like, if I had my own
practice, I'd probably buy it.
Dr. Shark Varshavski here. Is in.
Check out my video here
where I talk about the harsh reality
of being 800 plus pounds.
Click here. You won't regret it.
As always stay happy and healthy.
(heavy bass music)